[музика]
Отже розпочинаємо прес брифінг міністра
освіти і науки України Сергія шкарлута
щодо попередніх результатів вступної
кампанії 2022 року також на заході
присутня спікерів генеральний директор
директорату фахової передвищої вищої
освіти Міністерства освіти їх широв та
виконуючий обов'язки директора
українського центру оцінювання якості
освіти Валерій Бойко Я запрошую до слова
міністра освіти і науки України Сергія
шкарпеток будь ласка
Доброго дня шановні журналісти Доброго
дня шановні українці ви знаєте підійшов
черговий етап певних випробувань
2022 року освітніх випробувань які
сталися в системі освіти які
відзначилися певними досить вагомими і
результатами і оцінками За цей час ми на
сьогодні проводимо
попередні підсумки вступної кампанії
2022 року адже
враховуючи той воєнний стан враховуючи
ті
певні особливості цієї вступної кампанії
варто наголосити на декількох важливих і
фундаментальних принципіах формування
взагалі стратегії цієї освітньої
компанії підведення підсумків акцентів
які ми саме командою Міністерства
зробили на цій вступні кампанії
взагалі-то
[музика]
хочу сказати що команда Міністерства
освіти і науки
команда керівників закладів вищої освіти
фахової передвищує професійно-технічної
освіти взагалі Ми маємо всі стримані
оптимізм стосовно попередніх підсумків
цієї вступної кампанії які відзначились
перш за все тім що ми акцентували увагу
на збереження випускників цього року а
це більше ніж 340 тисяч випускників
дев'ятий класів 224 тисячі випускників
11 класів і саме головне що в період
воєнного часу воєнного стану ми мали
якомога більше зберегти наших
випускників саме в Україні зберегти цей
наш освітній потенціал для подальшого
відновлення найбільш найбільше гостроти
в 2022 році були деякі проблеми і
виклики які спричинили перш за все
повномасштабна агресія Російської
Федерації і Саме основне це ж загроза
життю і здоров'ю людей
учасники освітнього процесу обмеження
доступу до базових потреб які ми
вважаємо освіту це руйнування освітньої
інфраструктури адже на сьогодні ми маємо
значно більше ніж 2,5 тисячі в цілому
зруйнованих пошкоджених закладів освіти
це і вимушене масштабне переміщення
учасників освітнього процесу як
всередині країни так і за її межі
ускладнення до доступу щодо доступу до
освітніх послуг питання вимушеного
переміщення закладів фахової перевищує
вищої освіти і філії їх втрата
управлінського контролю на певних
територіях які на сьогодні окуповані і
також
суттєве зменшення фінансування і
вимушених вимушене існування в під час
зменшення видатків державного бюджету
Окрім цього обов'язкові обстріли бо
бомбардування ракетні обстріли майже по
всій території вступної нашої країни
суттєво зменшили терміни вступної
кампанії
саме завдячуючи
досить релевантним викликам
релевантним реакції на ці виклики ми
зробили разом з комітетом освіти науки
та інновації разом з народними
депутатами зробили
декілька суттєвих законодавчих змін щодо
формування більш якісної вступної
кампанії проведення державної
підсумкової атестації зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання єдиного вступного
іспиту та єдиного фахового вступного
випробування
в найкоротший терміни ми напрацювали
порядки прийому закладів професійної
фахової приміщення вищої освіти створили
всі умови до вступу щодо закладів освіти
громадян іноземців та здобуття фахової
перевищує вищої а також до осі пільгових
категорій відповідного рівня суттєво
збільшились спроможність вступу щодо
категорії з тимчасово окупованих або
тимчасових або найбільш небезпечних
територій і вступна кампанія 2022 року
стартувала 1 липня тривала до 30
листопада
2000 триватиме до 30 листопада 2022 року
Основний етап компанії розпочався 1
липня коли абітурієнти змогли
зареєструвати електронні кабінети і
завершився зарахуванням на навчання на
бюджет для здобуття
освітньо-професійного рівня фахового
молодшого Миколая молодшого бакалавр
бакалавра саме 5 вересня і на контракт
30 вересня 2022 року
на сьогодні ще триває процедура
завершення вступу до здобуття ступеня
магістра та додаткового набору на
вакантні місця ліцензійного обсягу для
здобуття освітнього ступеня молодшого
бакалавра і бакалав за кошти фізичних та
юридичних осіб які ж все ж таки ми
новації прийоми 2022 року запровадили
саме в цьому році замість 3 традиційних
вступних випробувань тобто ЗНО Єві єфви
і фвв у 2022 році були заплановані
проведені такі тестування Саме основне -
це національний мультиплектний тест для
здобуття вищої освіти на основі повної
загальної середньої освіти на всі
спеціальності кон'юнктурні та медичні
спеціальності Окрім цього ми запровадили
магістерський комплексний тест для
вступу на спеціальності право і
Міжнародне право а також магістерський
тест на навчальний компетентності для
вступу на спеціальності галузей шести
галузей знань Які найбільш кон'юнктурні
і в цьому році були визначені і як
соціальний та поведінкові науки
журналістика управління та
адміністрування публічне управління та
адміністрування міжнародні відносини
крім спеціальності міжнародне право
в чому все-таки були відмінності між
традиційним ЗНО та національним тестом
це перш за все формат тестування адже
проводилось це лише в один етап час і
місце тестування проведення і на
сьогодні національний мультиплектний
тест був проведений в рамках трьох сесій
основна сесія тривала він національний
мультиплектний складався з трьох
дисциплін історії України математика та
українська мова і складався в три сесії
основна з 18 липня по 10 серпня
додаткова 16 по 20 серпня і спеціальне з
12 по 16 серпня ми маємо на сьогодні
пишатися нашими
випускниками яких саме на основну сесію
ми зареєстрували 187 тисяч 782 учасника
на додаткову сесію 21
00018 вступників на спеціальну сесію
478ступників загалом участь у
національному мультиппредметному тесті
взяли 214 385 вступників з них 23 тисячі
38 осіб складали тестування за кордоном
в перший раз в історії незалежної
України
Європейські країни провідні країни світу
сьогодні стали на допомогу Україні стали
допомогу юним українцям і забезпечили
можливість навіть молодим випускникам
з-за кордону Приймати участь в конкурсі
на
місця державної контрактного замовлення
в заклади освіти України тестування
відбувалося в 21 одній області України
та місця Києві Адже всі інші області
були під ракетними та бомбовими та
європейськими область обстрілами і
безпекова ситуація не дозволяла
проводити
там тестування по національному мультику
предметному Та всім іншим тестуванням
Окрім цього в 32-х країнах світу були
організовані пункти по тестування
національним предметним тестам і в на
сайті Міністерства освіти цей повний
перелік і українського центру оцінювання
якості освіти є повний перелік цих країн
які надали повну підтримку нашим молодим
українцям
ну мабуть мабуть варто зазначити що
найбільший уваги було приковано до
Національного мультиплідного тесту та
його результатів і при цьому Я хочу ще
раз наголосити так званим диваном
експертам що наші діти гідно витримали
таку Так я Випробування під час війни
більше ніж 10 тисяч юних учасників
абітурієнтів які склали nmt отримали
200 балів хоча б з одного з предметів а
майже 600 вступників отримали 200 балів
по кожному з таких трьох предметів
загалом Отже 200 балів з тестування хоча
б з одного предмету
1028 учасників з двох предметів 1925 із
трьох 564 з української мови таких
учасників було
2898 осіб з історії України
4229 осіб з математики 6 тисяч 134 особи
окремою категорією окремим окремим
додатком до вступної кампанії в цьому
році виявився мотиваційний лист він
звично він запроваджений ще в минулому
році Але в цьому році мотиваційний лист
відігравав саме
інструменту яким би вдало які який теж
забезпечував одну з необхідних умов до
вступу з некон'юнктурних спеціальностей
і результати
мотиваційного листа були
єдиним критерієм для надання
рекомендації для зарахування на
некон'ютурній спеціальності на контракт
для вступників які зареєстровані на
особливо небезпечних територіях
творчий конкурси індивідуальні усні
співбесіди були
була надана можливість за їх зверненням
проводить дистанційно вперше реалізовано
подання заяв в електронній формі через
електронні кабінети для здобуття фахової
перевищення освіти на основі базової
середньої освіти
спеціальними умовами щодо участі в
конкурсному відборі користувалися особи
які в 2022 році здобули ступінь
бакалавра за такою спеціальності я не
купила на яку планували вступати в тому
числі і до магістратури
Окрім цього була надана перевага
можливості виконувати вимоги до
зарахування шляхом поєднання відповідних
документів електронною поштою з
накладанням електронного підпису для
вступника і така практика чудове
зарекомендувала себе у попередні роки і
сприйняла остаточно і сприяла
остаточному зникненню чергу приймальних
комісіях особливо
Хочу зазначити що ми забезпечили
можливість вступу з так званих особливо
небезпечних територій з Криму України з
Донбасу України з окупованих територій і
ті механізми які ми запровадили в цьому
році повна підтримка вступників з таких
територій можливість їх зарахування на
навчання за кошти державного замовлення
а також можливість їх вступу за
індивідуальним форматом в тому числі і
дистанційно дала можливість таким
суттєво збільшити в 5 разів збільшити
кількість таких абітурієнтів в
порівнянні з минулим роком якщо в
минулому році це було 2004 особи то в
цьому році майже 11 тисяч осіб які
вступили за Крим Україна донбас-україна
з окупованих територій особливо
небезпечних територій
[музика]
в принципі в мене все Я можливо в моїй
колеги доповнять
»
[музика]
.»
серед тих хто вступав В магістратуру
після бакалаврата кількість вступників
перевищили 16,000 складали практично 10%
від загальної кількості вступників
загалом це дуже високі цифри і причому
теж треба розуміти що більшість цих
вступників вони
репрезентували ті категорії вступників
які отримали пільги в цьому році в першу
чергу це мешканці так званих тимчасова
окупованих територій під час воєнного
стану території які знаходяться в
оточенні в блокуванні непідконтрольних
територій ті які ми зазвичай називаємо
особливо небезпечні території вступники
саме цієї категорії складають більшість
пільговиків серед усіх вступників
2020 року
також звичайно суттєво збільшилась
кількість вступників які мають пільги
дітей учасників бойових дій очікуємо
надалі суттєвого збільшення наступі і
самих учасників бойових дій осіб з
інвалідністю внаслідок війни а багато
було дуже розмов стосовно того наскільки
чітко
відбулося розрізнення вступників за
результатами національного мультику
предметного тесту Я не хочу Валерій
Іванович відбирати його хліб щодо
коментарів підсумків національного
мультику предметного теста але хочу
сказати що по такому параметру як
прохідний бал широкого конкурсу ми не
відчули суттєвих змін національного
мультику предметного тесту а порівняно з
зовнішнім незалежним оцінюванням
прохідні бали залишилися приблизно
такими самими Як у минулому році я хотів
би назвати кілька широких ресурсів де
прохідні бали в цьому році перевищували
190 балів
найбільш кунку найвищий конкурс був на
великий конкурсній групі до якої входить
ціла група спеціальностей економічних
управлінських спеціальності а державного
управління і сфери обслуговування і по
цій великій групі спеціальності конкурс
непрохідний бал широкого конкурсу
складав
194,5 на другому місці у нас групи
спеціальності політологія і міжнародні
відносини з прохідним балом 194
312-му місці практично традиційна
стоматологія на четвертому вправа і на
п'ятому місці найбільш конкурсні в цьому
році іноземні мови в цьому році найбільш
конкурсними іноземними умовами була
англійська в чому в принципі нічого
незвичайного і завжди тут є якась
особливість в цьому році в ролі
особливості
вийшло корейська мова А це ці
спеціальності для вступу на яких за
бюджетні місця було потрібно набрати
найвищі конкурсні бали і ті вступники
які вступили на бюджет а саме з цих
спеціальностей на загальному конкурсі
вони довели що вони мають дуже високий
рівень знань і зумогли це
продемонструвати з результатами
національного мультипрідного тесту дякую
Дякуємо але ж ігорчу
Запрошуємо до слова Валерія іваничу вас
Будь ласка
[музика]
український центр оцінює якості освіти
як установи яка впродовж 15 років
здійснювала
увесь процес підготовки і проведення
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання В
умовах воєнного стану в умовах війни
змушена була також реагувати на виклики
які поставили і перед нами за
ініціативою Міністерства освіти і науки
за підтримки цілої низки міжнародніх
українських партнерів була реалізована
платформа яка дала можливість вперше
провести онлайн тестування такого
масштабу який не очікував ніхто Чесно
кажучи в усьому світі за великим
рахунком я лише підкреслюю що понад 214
000 учасників пройшли національні
мультиплектний тест це величезна
кількість навіть в порівнянні з
класичним ЗНО коли ми обслуговували
потреби майже
350-300 тисяч щороку учасників
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання для
комп'ютерного роботу 214 тисяч це є
величезні об'єми і масиви даних Які ми
які опрацьовувалися українським центром
за великим рахунком вперше український
центр окрім основної і додаткової сесії
за ініціативи Міністерства освіти і
науки аби максимально врахувати всі
життєві обставини наших випускників які
з тих чи інших причин опинилися поза
межами свого традиційного
проживання навчання можливо й реалізації
власних мрій СБУ запроваджено і
проведено спеціальну сесію тестування 25
змін тестування за всі три періоди за
всі три сесії ми розуміючи всю безпекову
ситуацію яка існувала в країні наперед
не анонсували жодного жодного дня
проведення тестування ми жодного разу
ніде в публічному просторі окрім періоду
Впродовж якого здійснювалася основна
додаткова і спеціальна сесія не
артикулювали перед не тільки української
громадськістю в першу чергу перед нашими
ворогами країни-агресору то ті місця і
міста де будуть відбуватися Основні
додаткові спеціальні сесії завдячуючи
зусиллям обласних військових
адміністрацій місцевій владі студелося
створити максимально зручній безпекові
безпечні умови проведення тестування ми
проводили тестування двічі на день
до обіду і по обіді фактично дві сесії
лише тільки з огляду на повітряну
тривогу і небезпеку ми переривали
тестування даючи можливість дітям і
учасникам
процесу які обслуговували безпосередню
роботу тимчасових екзаменаційних центрів
спускатися в укриття аби пережидати
безпосередньо повітряну тривогу і
повертатися до тестування лише виключно
після того як повітря на тривога на
національному або обласному рівні
відбивалися за великим рахунком створити
в доволі таки складних умовах мінливості
щоденної ситуації 1 133 тимчасових
екзаменаційних центрів забезпечити їх
всіма необхідними
внутрішніми
внутрішнім устаткуванням і
задіяти більше 20 тисяч аудиторій
залучити більше 18 тисяч педагогічних
працівників це був той виклик з яким
український центр повторюють за
підтримки усього освітянського нашого
середовища впорався і впорався Я вважаю
на відміну
великим рахунком в межах основних
додаткових сесій в Україні і в 32-х
країнах світу було проведено
національному та предметним тестування
фактично ми можемо виділити пол з трьох
типів країн Це ті країни в яких
відбувалися виключно основна сесія та ті
країни де відбувалися і основна і
додаткова сесія і країни в яких
відбувалися виключно спеціально сесія це
пов'язана не забаганками українського
центру або Міністерства освіти і науки
це було пов'язано виключно з
організаційними спроможностіми тієї чи
іншої країни в повній мірі забезпечити
потреби тих дітей які перебувають але в
тій чи іншій країні підкреслю що
найбільша кількість дітей які проходили
тестування за кордоном були зосереджені
безпосередньо в Польщі і безпосередньо в
Німеччині там близько 7 і трохи більше
6000 осіб відповідно з огляду на те що
на відміну від класичного ЗНО під час
визначення результатів національного
тесту не застосовувалися така процедура
як встановлення порога склав не склав
фактично левова частка учасників які
реєструвалися і проходили тестування як
під час основної додаткової спеціальної
сесії отримали результати і з такими У
такий спосіб здобули шанс брати участь у
конкурсному випробуванні до омріяного
університету основні результати ммт
міністр вже підкреслив і сказав про те
що наші діти дійсно неймовірні вони
дивовижні вони продемонстрували найкращі
свої результати майже 3 000 учасників
отримали 200 бальні результати з
української мови
4229 учасників з історії України
6134 учасників з математики ми
переконані що ці діти стали гідними
студентами і продемонструють свої
найкращі результати під час навчання в
українських вишах за великим рахунком
результати які продемонстрували наші
діти на діаграмі легко бачити що в шкалі
100 200 ми не спостерігаємо жодного з
предметів із української мови Ні з
історії України ні з математики
провальних результатів фактично ми
бачимо що
наша популяція рівномірно
розподіляється на шкалі від 100 до 200
балів Звичайно що з перевагою учасників
які мають середні результати інтервалів
від 140 до 160 балів але Зверніть увагу
що є йти учасники їх значно більше з
української мови і трошки менше з
математики які отримують високі
результати в інтервалі шкали від 160 до
180 балів і в інтервалі шкали від 180 до
200 балів якщо подивитися на результати
учасників регіональному розрізі А я
наголошую що український центр завершив
основну процедуру реєстрації ще на етапі
класичного ЗНО і нам дуже легко
ідентифікувати дитину за місцем її
реєстрації якщо подивитися на кольорову
гаму на кожний з предметів з української
мови з математики з історії України ми
не побачимо жодної області яка була б
або аутсайдером або продемонстрували
якийсь би провал в організації
освітнього процесу наслідком якого стали
результати з української мови з
Математики історії України всі області
мають приблизно однакові результати по
тим категоріям учасників які брали
участь в національному мультипредметному
тесті Якщо ж говорити за ознакою статі
за розподілом результатів між дівчинками
та хлопчиками ми також не бачимо якоїсь
суттєвої переваги Ну можливо за
виключенням математики наші хлопці
можливо Трохи вправніші але дівчатка
демонструють чудові результати на своїх
найвищих результатах з української мови
і з історії України до речі така
тенденція прослідковувалася і впродовж
попередніх 15 років проведення
класичного зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання Якщо говорити про категорію
учасників тестування Звичайно що нашими
левоми левова частка наших учасників це
випускники закладів загальної середньої
освіти
71% випускники минулих років трохи
більше 15 це студенти коледжів трохи
більше
10%. Ну і учні закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти майже три
відсотки з усіх трьох предметів ми
бачимо що так чи інакше випускники
закладів загальної середньої освіти
демонструють кращі результати але при
самому всі чотири озвучені мною
категорії не демонструють якихось
повторюсь провальних результатів ми
маємо учасників які заслуговують на
найвищі оцінки і демонструють найвищий
свій результат в будь-якій підгрупі
учасників які реєструвалися для
проходження національного та предметного
тесту і всі вони здобули право участі в
конкурсному випробуванні До закладів
вищої освіти цікавими є результати
розподілу учасників по розташуванню
закладів освіти місто Селище село селища
міського типу Звичайно що місцяни
традиційно можливо над цим ще працювати
і наші всі освітянські спільноті
демонструють кращі результати але при
цьому діти пересічного села не пасуть
задніх там також є відмінники там також
є учасники які згідно посідають
свої місця на найближчих щаблях
рейтингового списку за шкалою 100-200
балів Ну і відповідно Якщо говорити про
розподіл ще по такій категорії
результатів учасників національного типу
предметного тесту за закладами освіти то
Зрозуміло знов-таки якщо подивитися на
результаті в розрізі предметів
української мови математики історії
України типи закладів гімназії ліцей
колегіуми заклади загальної освіти
навчально-виховні комплекси демонструють
приблизно однакові результати і
незалежно від того де навчається дитина
в елітному ліцеї чи в звичайній
пересічній Можливо навіть і не міській
школі вона також за налеумовно належної
підготовки до проходження національного
та предметного тесту демонструє доволі
такі пристойні результати Ну і
насамкінець хотілось би зазначити що
національний мультиппредметний тест
успішно проведено І нами створено усі
передумови для успішною вступної
кампанії
2022 року Дякую
Валерій Іванович шановні журналісти
[музика]
нацистська прошу вас
Ігор Бондаренко телеканал 1+1 у мене
уточнення по цифрам скільки студентів
першокурсників у нас в цьому році
Скільки з них поступили саме в ВУЗи за
кордоном
і була друге запитання була проблема із
виїздом саме студентів які навчаються за
кордоном через те що хлопці
військовозобов'язані і ті хто старший 18
років їх не випускали з-за кордону чи
вирішилася ця проблема яким чином
кількість вступників всього на всі три
сесії в нас 214
388 вступників з них 23 тисячі 38 осіб
складали тест за кордоном з цих 214
тисяч щодо виїзду студентів які вступили
на навчання До закладів іноземних
закладів освіти на сьогодні
під час воєнного стану виїзд чоловіків з
18 до 60 років є забороненими
Міністерство освіти і науки ніяким чином
немає відношення щодо
дозвілу або не дозволу перетинання
кордонів цим займається Державна
прикордонна служба до Міністерства
освіти і науки регулярно щоден
надходить велика кількість звернень від
громадян України від
університетів щодо тих чи інших
особистих заяв громадян України щодо
перетинання кордону Міністерство освіти
України пересилає їх за належністю до
Державної прикордонної служби яка далі
приймає рішення по за сутністю проблем
на сьогодні
Міністерство освіти і науки
лише може мати компетенції в тих
аспектах коли наприклад наше студенти
які по міжнародних договорах за
попередні роки навчання
навчаються або приймають участь в таких
програмах наприклад як еразмус або в
інших
програмах на кшталт еразмуса між
університетських обмінах або навчається
за кошти держави Україна поміж державних
обмінах це короткотермінові виїзди це
короткотермінове перетинання кордону але
все-таки Міністерство освіти іноді за
належністю опрацьовує листи направляє їх
за належністю державного прикордонної
служби яка приймає рішення щодо
перетинання кордону
Дякую за запитання Дякую Сергій Миколаю
є ж питання Серед присутніх немає тут у
нас було питання вже Залишені в
попередній формі то ми теж як задано
питання було видано зрения 1+1 яка
допомога передбачена для студентів
внутрішньо переміщених осіб та жителів з
особливо небезпечних територій України
дуже слушне запитання адже мабуть
території які
особливо небезпечні території які
анексовані території які окуповані
мешканці цих територій мабуть потребують
найбільшої підтримки сьогодні від
держави найбільшої підтримки від усіх
сфер в тому числі від освітянської
галузі відповідно до порядку прийому
вступників в залежності від місця
проживання на території Автономної
Республіки Крим або на територіях
Донецької Луганської області або на вони
могли скористатися спрощеною процедурою
вступу і ніяких попередні роки за через
центри освітні центри крим-україна
Донбас України
вступники які
зареєстровані на особливо небезпечних
територіях в цьому році мали можливість
вступати за квотою два яка була
розширена від 10 до 40%
у приміщених закладах освіти від
максимального обсягу державного
замовлення це означає що і саме цією
процедурою скористалися більше ніж 11
тисяч учасників порівнянні з минулим
роком коли їх було
2004 таких учасника
яка ж цільова підтримка надавалася таким
особам перш за все це соціальна
стипендія для осіб які навчаються за
державним у регіональним замовленням на
денній формі здобуття освіти друге - це
безоплатне забезпечення підручниками за
рахунок бібліотечного фонду відповідного
закладу освіти це безоплатний доступ до
інтернету система баз даних у державних
комунальних закладах освіти безоплатне
проживання в учнівських та студентських
гуртожитках або проживання в
студентських гуртожитках за пільговою
оплатою для осіб які навчаються за
денною формою здобуття освіти
також уряд зараз опрацьовує питання щодо
переведення на за на навчання за кошти
державного бюджету з студентів
контрактників старший курсів другого
третього четвертого курсу магістратури
які проживають або перемістилися з
тимчасово окупованих територій територій
які
розташовані в зоні проведення бойових
дій або перебувають в тимчасові окупації
дякую дякую у вас що було питання так
представтесь будь ласка теж
і на горіненко канал Рада щодо ситуації
із дистанційним навчанням яка силу
обставин пов'язано було з коронавірусом
тепер і з воєнним станом Які взагалі є
перспективи для того щоб не втратити
соціалізацію учнів і студентів які
розглядаєте плани перспективи на те щоб
були або змішані форми навчання або яким
чином тобто зрозуміло що дрони Камікадзе
літати не перестануть але все-таки як
буде відбуватися соціалізація студентів
тому що наприклад є і лабораторні роботи
ще якісь історії які все-таки виключно
на домашньому дистанційному навчанні
бути не можуть
ви знаєте я вам хочу сказати Ну перш за
все на сьогодні
в безпековій ситуації згідно з
перевірками комісії Ми більше ніж 25
тисяч закладів освіти перевірили
спільними комісіями і ДСНС і військових
адміністрацій Міністерства освіти
державної служби якості нацполіції майже
63% закладів відповідають безпечним
умовам згідно нормативів ДСНС в яких
проведення можливо з повною
соціалізацією в яких враховані всі
безпекові умови і різного типу укриття і
на сьогодні
незважаючи на дрони незважаючи на
обстріли незважаючи на постріли і
обстріли 17
я не буду називати ті громади які вже
перейшли в тому числі більшу частину на
змішану форму для того щоб забезпечити
хоча б мінімальну соціалізацію можливо
це не буде там 5 років 6 повноформатний
режим але 2-3 уроки саме для
забезпечення соціалізації сьогодні в
Україні є в нас якщо брати повну
загальну середню освіту То майже 70%
шкіл готові до
69,4% шкіл якщо точно готові до
повноформатного навчання і в нас Майже
[музика]
7700 шкіл які працювали в
повноформатному або змішаному форматі
навчання забезпечуючи
повноцінну соціалізацію дітей лише
більше ніж 5 тисяч шкіл працювали
виключно в режимі онлайн адже цього
вимагала безпекова ситуація але навіть в
режимі онлайн ковід нам дуже допоміг в
тому що ми мали можливість після першого
року ці чітко оцінити втрату якості
навчання ми чітко опрацювали ті питання
по яких саме по яких критеріях і саме
причини втрати якості навчання і
допрацювали і в тому числі нашу
національну
онлайн-платформу всеукраїнська школа
онлайн доповнили її певними модульними
блоками які б забезпечили можливість
побудови індивідуальної траєкторії
вчителя з кожним учнем для того щоб
певним чином повернутися до контролю
залишкових знань після певних тем
сформувати можливо тих учнів які певну
тему не
засвоїли на
наявний необхідний рівень залишкової
знань і саме тому сьогодні
навіть в жорстких умовах воєнного стану
ми в принципі готові для гідного
представлення наших дітей і цьому
показали Навіть наші опитування тих
дітей які виїхали незважаючи на
дворічний кавіт виїхали за територію
України навчаються в школах
Європейського Союзу я спілкувався зі
своїми колегами міністрами які просто
захоплюються рівнем знань наших учнів
рівних рівнем знань наших дітей і якістю
є педагогічної майстерністю наших
педагогів дякую
ще одне запитання як планується
організовувати оцінювання учнів
випускних класів у наступному році
мається на увазі 1022-23 навчальний рік
[музика]
випускний класи на сьогодні ну
традиційно згідно закону про
загальну середню освіту згідно закону
про вищу освіту згідно закону Про освіту
Ми вже мали підготувати певні нормативні
документи щодо впровадження
основного інструменту оцінювання якості
залишкових знань після опанування
програми повної загальної середньої
освіти тобто нашого традиційного
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання що ми
вже зробили і подали всі необхідні
документи для опрацювання вступу в
стандартному форматі зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання в залежності від
того скільки і як буде тривати воєнний
стан в Україні ми все одно для себе
вирішили що ми маємо мати альтернативи
вступу 2023 році
альтернативний вступ який був
забезпечений 22-му році інструментом
національного мультику предметного тесту
виправдав свою
виправдав себе і Але ми не зупиняємось
на традиційному форматі вже традиційному
форматі nmt ми для
формування вступної кампанії сьогодні
готові в декількох варіантів з
традиційної класичної зовнішнє незалежне
оцінювання і
оновлений варіант національного
мультиплітудного тесту який буде
враховувати побажання в тому числі і
певних груп категорій які не завжди
вивчали наприклад історію України і
диференціювалися за рівнем хімії
біології іноземної мови Дякую вам
Дякуємо На цьому наш прес брифінг
закінчено Дякуємо всім за увагу Дякую
Вам слава Україні
[музика]